Our first speaker
is Laura Wexler.
Laura is Professor
of American Studies,
Professor of Women's, Gender,
and Sexuality Studies,
Professor of Film and Media
Studies at Yale University.
She's a busy person.
Professor Wexler is Co-Director
of Yale Public Humanities,
Founding Director of Yale's
Photographic Memory Workshop,
a member of the Steering
Committee of the Feminist
Technology Network, and
Principal Investigator
of the Photogrammar Project.
She has served as Chair of the
Women's, Gender, and Sexuality
Studies Program and Co-Chair
of the Women's Faculty Forum.
Professor Wexler has
an undergraduate degree
from Sarah Lawrence College,
and MA, M.Phil, and PhD
degrees from
Columbia University.
Welcome Professor Wexler.
Thank you very much, and
thank you to the organizers
for inviting me.
All right, so--
Microphone.
OK.
So in the summer of 1935,
economist Rexford Tugwell,
who was a former
Columbia University
professor of economics and the
current head of the Roosevelt
Administration's
Resettlement Administration,
created an information
division for his agency.
And he appointed to that
information division
another, younger Columbia
University economist,
Roy Stryker, to lead its
historical section that
was going to be a
public relations unit.
The need was dire.
The Resettlement Administration
had replaced the Agricultural
Adjustment Administration after
the former agency had created
an unforeseen crisis, on top of
the already critical situation
of American agriculture
in the Depression.
By paying farmers to reduce
agricultural production,
the earlier government
agency had successfully
raised commodity prices,
which was its goal.
But simultaneously, it
started pushing small farmers
and sharecroppers out of
their livelihood, which
was its unintended consequence.
Family farms were being
hit by a triple whammy.
Modernization
brought large scale
industrial farming, with which
it was difficult to compete.
Loss of American market
share to European farms
that were now recovering from
the devastation of World War I
brought further competition.
And extensive and
extended drought,
combined with inexpert
land management,
brought the ecological
emergency of the Dust Bowl.
Hundreds of thousands of
formerly independent farm
families were being
rapidly thrown
into the migrant
transitory labor market.
The Resettlement Agency,
like other New Deal agencies,
was set up to
mitigate the damage,
and Roosevelt's
enemies in Congress
were poised to stop it.
The main job of the Historical
Division of the Resettlement
Administration, therefore, was
to practice a public relations
policy that would be
as potent as possible.
The task was bureaucratic.
They were to supply
media with photographs
that showed the success of
the government's programs.
Stryker hired an extraordinary
group of photographers,
including Dorothea Lange,
Walker Evans, Gordon Parks,
and sent them out on field
assignments to do this work.
They would work, basically
on the jobs he scripted.
But in the interstices,
he promised
they would be able to take
a day here, a day there.
That's part of why they signed
up for the government job,
because you could do
that, to explore material
that particularly
interested them.
This is where, as he
later would put it,
they conspired with him to
get what history has proved
to be the guts of the project.
Ultimately, the greatest success
of the Historical Division
of the Resettlement
Administration
accomplished its goals
of introducing Americans
to Americans.
But not only during the Great
Depression, but also long
after.
In fact, when we
in the 21st century
want to look back and see who
we once were in order to picture
and assess who we
are now becoming,
it is very often to the
FSA photographic archive
that we turn.
The FSA photographs
represent the largest,
indeed the only, large
scale government-sponsored
documentary project in
United States history.
The nearly 170,000
surviving photographs
of the more than 250,000
the agency produced,
in the 10 years
between 1935 and 1945,
reside at the Library of
Congress, where access to them
is public and rights
of reproduction
are essentially free.
They are also available
for search and download
on the Library of
Congress website.
They are widely recognized
as one of the treasures
of the American people.
Arguably, the FSA
photographers were
more successful
than the agencies
they were created to support.
The baseline idea was to improve
the lives of marginal farmers
by purchasing some marginal
land and relocating individual,
and often isolated, families
to better land on group
farms, where economies
could be more efficient
and scientific expertise
could be learned, shared,
and consolidated.
Aggressively attacked
by congressional critics
as collectivized agriculture,
the movers and shakers
of the resettlement
administration
were very often on the
defensive, their budgets
repeatedly slashed.
Instead of success, in
Tugwell's original goal
of moving 650,000
people sustainably
onto 100 million
acres of new land,
they were only able
to move a few thousand
people onto 9 million acres.
Instead, they were forced to
build about 75 relief camps
in California, where about
75,000 destitute migrants, who
were almost entirely
unwelcome in the state,
were temporarily housed in clean
quarters with running water.
They also built a few
greenbelt model cities
for a future that never came.
In 1936, facing widespread
criticism Rexford Tugwell
resigned.
And in 1937, the
Resettlement Administration
was transferred to the
Department of Agriculture,
and the Farm Security Act
transformed it into the Farm
Security Administration.
One can, and many have and
do, argue the relative value
of the farming programs.
One particularly stinging
criticism concerns
the basic structural, and
also actively overt, racism
that underlay the project,
often creating disparities
in who was portrayed
as the deserving poor.
Whose histories of the land
are envisioned and respected,
and whose were erased,
and who received relief.
Key FSA programs
removed former tenants
and replaced them
with FSA clients
throughout the Mississippi
Delta, both black and white.
But racial segregation
was accepted.
Black clients at the time
were unable to challenge
such policies.
But it has also been argued
that the agency itself
created the ideological and
practical infrastructure
through which the black
farmers would eventually
challenge the white
supremacy of resettlement.
This documentary
project, however,
the photographic
project is generally
considered to be an
astounding success.
If the more than 170,000 extant
and widely beloved photographs
contain exculpatory or
contradictory evidence
about the intentions and
effects of New Deal policies,
it is very difficult,
however, to turn it up.
The FSA archive is a very
large, very messy data set.
Enter Photogrammar, a
digital research tool
supported by the
NEH and the ACLS,
and developed at Yale by
the Photogrammar team.
The team consists of two
co-directors, former Yale
graduate students Taylor
Arnold in Statistics and Lauren
Tilton in American Studies,
and they're both now
at the University of Richmond.
Stacey Maples,
former GIS librarian
at Yale, and now at
the David Ramsey Map
Center at Stanford University.
Kenneth Panko, former Yale
technologist, now at Yale NUS.
Peter Leonard, Yale's first
digital humanities librarian
and head of the DH Lab in
Sterling Memorial Library.
Trip Kirkpatrick, technologist
in Yale's Teaching and Learning
Laboratory.
And myself, after
six years, profoundly
a digitally-enhanced humanist,
I am the principal investigator
of the Photogrammar Project.
One intervention that
we immediately made
was to create a web-based,
many-layered interactive
geospatial map to render this
archive fluently searchable.
And you see in this slide
the mapping that resulted.
And when we did this,
absolutely immediately we
overturned the first
stereotypical truism
that scholars have,
since the 1930s,
been repeating about
this project, which
is that it is about
Appalachia and the Dust Bowl.
The minute that you map the
photographs, what you find
is that it's a project
of national scope.
And that it covers not
only from Maine to Florida,
there's even sites
offshore, but also
the old industrial cities,
as well as the Heartland
and the farmland of the country.
And why this is and why
it keeps getting repeated,
that really it's about
Appalachian and the Okies
moving west to
California, is something
that I believe that mapping
and studying the FSA
archive as a big messy
data set will eventually
allow us to learn about.
So let me just give
you a quick torrent,
slides of the web site.
You will recognize many
of these photographs.
They are not only our
cultural heritage,
but our cultural imaginary of
who we were during the Great
Depression.
These are Walker
Evans' photographs
of the sharecroppers that
were published in the book
Let Us Now Praise Famous
Men that he coauthored
with James Agee.
This is the office of the
women in the back offices, who
were categorizing and tagging
the hundreds of thousands
of photographs as they
came in, under the auspices
of a brilliant librarian named
Paul Vanderbilt. This was
Vanderbilt's first
effort at tagging,
actually creating visual
categories for photographs.
He went on to head the
Wisconsin Historical Society
and do incredible work there.
But these are the labor force
behind what Vanderbilt was
doing, and they are anonymous.
The FSA files exist
in red file cabinets
in the Library of Congress
now as analog objects,
material objects.
And they also exist
online in the Library
of Congress website.
But both of these are very,
very difficult to search.
In 2001, I was part of a small
group of scholars brought
to the Library of Congress
to search physically
through these drawers and
find interesting information
about the FSA photographs
that we didn't already know.
And out of the, I think
probably eight or nine of us,
very little new interesting
information resulted from that.
Because even in a week of
looking, it's too unwieldy,
it's too difficult, there
are too many factors,
there's too much information
to search that way.
And this is one of the reasons
that the Photogrammar Project
got started.
So here's the map.
And we also took 10 of the
primary, most famous, most
well-known photographers,
and gave them colors,
and tracked their trail
across the country.
And we interleaved this
with a 1937 highway map.
Because if you're looking
for mystified or occluded
political choices in where
the FSA was doing its work,
one of the ways to
try to figure that out
is to see whether the people
doing field work were following
the main transportation routes,
were going on the back roads,
were relating to minority
communities or not,
it's the roadmap that
can tell you that.
We also discovered this.
The blue dots that
we first thought
were Route 66 going west,
it's actually a train.
It's not Route 66 at all.
So that's the trip going west.
We really threaded
the needle, in terms
of a digital humanities project,
with the Photogrammar Project
because this is open
access, open data that's
owned by the people
of the United States.
And so we were able, with
the tremendous, tremendous,
wonderful willing cooperation
of the Library of Congress,
we were able to work with
the beautifully-digitized
photographs that
they, twice, did
in two different generations
of digital capacity
and put online.
And with the metadata that they
also, as wonderful librarians,
kept attached, this is
public open information.
When we've presented this
project in other fora,
other groups of people have
said, well, could we do, could
we do Photogrammar on our--
The US Holocaust
Memorial Museum wanted
to do a Photogrammar kind of
map with letters and photographs
and information that
people were sending them.
But it turns out that
there are restrictions
on the information.
It's a proprietary archive.
Again and again and
again, people contact us.
We say all of our coding, all of
our information, is on GitHub.
It's all free for you.
Talk to us, we're
happy to help you.
And they cannot do this
work because the foresight
or happenchance or whatever it
is of the government, in 1936,
made this a public archive.
And so you see something
we've circled here
on the attached metadata
called lot number.
And that has to do with
the original coding system
then Vanderbilt, in that
room of workers, was doing.
And we also got a hold of
Vanderbilt's key handbook
and we coordinated
his categories
with these
photographs, so that we
can see how he
and the government
and the general
media were thinking
of this portrait of
Americans at the time.
One of the categories
we actually love
is "people as such," without
emphasis on their activity.
That is actually one
of his categories.
"People as such."
I think this may be one
of the "people as such."
But what you see is that,
because these photographs are
publicly owned, scholars
of the United States
have gone to this archive to
get images for their books
and articles without
much expense,
and you can always
get permission.
And what that means
is there's been,
I don't know what
a scientist would
call it, but a high replication
effect of a limited number
of photographs.
And so we actually
only a small amount
of what the images
are in this archive.
And every single time
I open up Photogrammar,
I find new images.
One of the innovations
of Photogrammar, so
what Stryker and the team
were doing in the 1930s
was turning data into images.
The government had
data [? where ?]
the agencies working, and he
was turning it into images
so that Americans could see and
understand who one another are.
What we have done
with those images
is to turn them back
into data, which gives us
now another way of searching,
combining, inquiring,
and understanding the nature
of this photographic system,
and how it applies
to our political past
and our current situation.
This is a treemap we
made Vanderbilt's 1942
classification system.
You can see "people as such."
You drill down into
it in three segments,
and you see what
they're looking for.
Horse shows, circus, dance,
orchestras, group singing.
This is the way
they are thinking
of a portrait of the country.
Is it our portrait
of the country?
No.
What's interesting
is the difference
between that portrait
of the country
and our portrait of the country.
I'm going to go very quickly
through and hope to show you
one more thing.
There are color ones.
Hardly anybody knew that.
We have been using
facial recognition
to categorize the photographs.
This is not very theoretically
well-substantiated.
We are looking for
morphological features
and trying to see what kind
of, we're just experimenting
with the images and trying
to see what kind of pictures
we get.
And can we actually find
more African-Americans,
visible African-Americans,
this way.
And then finally,
I want to tell you
a story that would
never have happened
if it wasn't this kind of a
group, this kind of a totally
inter-disciplinary,
cross-disciplinary group
with technologists, a
digital humanities librarian.
Me, I'm a historian
of photography.
Someone who had worked in
museums, a statistician, a GIS
expert.
This is our team.
We were in Washington
and talking
to Beverly Bannon,
who's the chief
[? curator ?] of this archive.
We were around a table
and Taylor Arnold,
this statistics grad
student, he finished his PhD,
but at the time, was
sitting in a corner
and he was looking at this
call number lalalala-M4.
And he says, what
does that mean, M4?
And the librarian
says, we don't know.
We don't know,
but best practices
are to keep the MARC record,
keep the metadata, intact.
So in all these years,
the librarians in Congress
did that.
What is this M number?
And after thinking about
it for a long time,
Taylor and Lauren figured
out is that M number
has to do with this.
The government
photographers were supplied
by government supplies.
And it was cheaper to give
them a large, industrial roll
of film than the film that,
those of you who would even
remember film will
remember, used to come
in 24- and 36-exposure rolls.
So they had large
rolls, and they
were constrained to
go out in the field
and shoot pictures and
send a rolls of film
back to Washington, where a
lab developed and printed them.
And then there's a
process of choosing.
So the lab did this, and
it caught the rolls of film
into about six- or
eight-frame segments.
When they were done,
they threw the segments
into a metaphorical pot.
They were not
interested in keeping
the segments aggregated.
They were looking
for individual images
to substantiate reports
in government documents.
So they threw these, OK.
So what Taylor figured
out is that the M number
had to do with which frame
it is on the negative strip.
And when he was able
to write a program
that could re-unify
the negative strips.
So here's an example, John
Vachon in July of 1941.
He's in Wisconsin and
he's photographing cheese.
Cheese, cheese, cheese,
cheese, cheese, cheese, cheese.
Then there's a blank.
There's a blank frame.
And that blank frame represents,
actually, his crossing.
The next frame is to Chicago,
where that next picture
is as a down-and-out
man sitting,
I guess it's on a fire hydrant.
And then the train of
thought, the shooting,
goes to photographing that man.
Now, it's absolutely
extraordinary.
We've been able to reunify
a certain a number of these.
And we now have a
grant, Taylor and Lauren
are working on this in Richmond,
to reunify many, many more.
But what you have here,
or now the historian,
is this question.
Why is the jump
from stop cheese,
then you can figure I'm tired of
cheese, to this man in Chicago.
And the question for a
Depression historian,
the question that
arises here is,
is John Vachon thinking we make
so much cheese in this country,
Wisconsin is not very
far from Chicago,
what is the reason we cannot
get the cheese to the people who
are hungry?
Cheese now comes in aid baskets.
And I wonder whether this
is a prehistory of that.
But the question is
a question that goes
to the heart of the New Deal.
Do we need a different kind
of production and distribution
system in order to
get what is needed
to the people who need it?
That's the question.
So, all right.
So Roy Stryker's
brilliant photographers
transformed data
into photographs.
I've said that the
brilliant Photogrammar
team has transformed these
photographs back into data.
The enduring question is, from
a digitally-enhanced humanist
point of view, cui bono?
Who benefits from this
knowledge, and how?
Thank you.